just as a quick background human
embryonic stem cells are very amazing
cells I can make all cells in the human
body so that's anything you can think of
like brain or skin of a muscle this
seems not very interesting until you
begin to consider how if we can use stem
cells to treat or cure human disease and
human suffering and so if you think
about it lots of human diseases like
diabetes or Parkinson's disease or even
aging or because a certain kind of cell
in the human body is lost so for example
in diabetes your pancreatic cells are
lost and you can't make any more insulin
or in spinal cord injury you lose your
spinal cord cells and you can't move
anymore and this is very devastating so
if human embryonic stem cells can make
all cells in the human body then
theoretically if you have spinal cord
injury we could take human embryonic
stem cells making new infinite number of
spinal cord cells and surgically put
them back into a spinal cord and restore
a function of that and try to bring
function back to your muscles and
conceptually we can extend this to any
range of disease and and I think that
many people really look to stem cells as
kind of a second generation of medicine
that right now we just give you drugs or
pills or shots that basically chemicals
that try to restore some kind of
biological function but with stem cells
what we're talking about is that if
you're missing cells that we can just
put them right back into you and that
this kind of treatment called
regenerative medicine we think is very
very cool
realistically that this might even be in
the decades range and so I think well
that this is somewhat disappointing many
animal experiments with diseases like
diabetes and Parkinson's disease have
already shown that stem cells have
remarkable ability to help treat or even
fully cure many kinds of diseases and
recently the FDA approved the shoot
first human embryonic stem cell based
clinical trial and this was for spinal
cord injury
I think that while it this has made it
sound human embryonic stem cells
sometimes remarkable as you probably
know there's a lot of ethical and moral
considerations about remember ionic stem
cells and I think the fact that they are
so clinically powerful but that they are
some that there's a lot of
considerations involved makes this very
complicated and this is because as the
world Shoom embryonic stem cell implies
that these cells are taken from a human
embryo and so I think very unfortunately
oftentimes when we take these human
embryonic stem cells from the MV o it
leads to the collapse of the human
embryo and so it can no longer develop
on is an alternative around this so
obviously there's a very big promise
with human embryonic stem cells how they
can help cure disease and that I think
that it'd be really awesome if we could
find a new way to get them without
having to destroy human embryo and so
recently there's a new technology called
the programming that's come up I told
you before that embryonic stem cells can
make all cells of the body and so what
we're thinking with reprogramming is of
what if we can turn any cell into an
embryonic stem cell the significance of
this is that if we can take any old cell
lying around and we can make it into an
embryonic stem cell then we can
basically make infinite amounts of human
embryonic stem cells without ever
touching a human embryo or harming a
human life and I think that this is a
big step to unlocking the widespread
usage and ethical usage of human
embryonic stem cells and that I know
that at least some politicians and
religious officials agree that this is a
very big step at Harvard we're very
interested in how it works and so that's
part of what I do that comes in there
are these three genetic switches that if
we turn on we believe we can make many
kinds of cells into human embryonic stem
cells or human embryonic like cells and
that this kind of reprogramming if we
want to bring it to the clinic we have
to thank how this is going to work how
we can take cells from patients and turn
them into stem cells and so there are
several ways to do this and very
unfortunately the biggest way right now
is to use viruses and that doesn't
really make sense because if we're using
viruses to make stem cells and we
eventually want to be able to use these
stem cells secure patients there's a
logical catch right there and so um
there's several other techniques but
what our group is trying to investigate
is whether or not we can use chemicals
to turn cells into stem cells and so
basically at Harvard our group what we
do is that we basically have lots of
cells and we test thousands of chemicals
on them this is called a chemical
library and we see if any of these
chemicals can turn the cell
than to remember Yannick stem cells and
I think that one day the goal would be
really that if we could just take a
cocktail of chemicals dump it on to any
cell and turn it into an embryonic stem
cell that can drive clinical therapies
and can drive research